hey what's up friend hey buddy
terrifying you are equally as bad I am
at I didn't mean to spurn at you any new
so I don't know which one you are I what
Oh your granny nips I'm green yeah I've
got some super boner bills
oh this is wonderful a child who learned
how to walk you can spread like a child
who learned how to walk okay how do i
how do I open doors and [ __ ] F some
doors open automatically when you run at
them wait the elevators say to hell oh
my god printing is opie yeah oh there is
a stamina bar god it's happening people
I don't know no where don't worry about
it are you our dearest old people I
don't know that I wanted to show you
guys something you're super boner do you
have a super boner whoa hey wait come
here I want to show you some hey I don't
know some cool just wait for it wait for
it himself
[Applause]
I bought some nippers how'd you get here
purrs oh thank you you're so nice oh
this is fun there's a lot of colors in
this world now what's the gastric lavage
Oh time to go to our seduction sedation
seduction rooms
seductive sedation opening I'm being
dragged away and I'm very druggie
boy damn it this really [ __ ] up dude I
don't even know what I'm doing right now
so on fire mark what did you do anything
yet dude I'm sending you to hell apart I
don't like this woken you just say back
to hell and now I respawn
where you went to hell oh wait hang on I
might be onto something efforts hey how
do you know what I crafted all is dead I
don't know but I got pillo hump plus
that's a thing it's not dying it's this
it's not dying from in here [ __ ] sorry I
didn't know I didn't know I didn't know
Oh someone crafted a razor blade I don't
make them here oh wait so you can only
get us when we craft something no we can
get you any time oh we can see what you
craft so different things cure different
ailments we have to kind of guess what
we think they're gonna cry Bob might
light himself a fire Jack I'm a follow
mark around no no no you don't you
follow me nothing you use that I don't
have a cure for whatever it is you're
holding okay cool fine don't worry about
it
go get it go get it I'm about to kill
myself successfully mark don't worry
about it yeah I'm woke it's out by the
pool I'm here got horny boy pills wait
take these actually have fun where you
have them no nah there's more than three
different types okay so watch this
you're gonna see something amazing as
soon as I find the third piece of the
puzzle
[Music]
all right it's fine so sickening Jack I
don't think we're gonna get me there
buddy
okay wait no that's yay that's our team
yeah you guys go you guys be the other
one
this game is [ __ ] up yeah no don't do
that please let us die do the opposite
of back world anymore it's muffin time
you all what you doing here buddy
hey Oh what you craft in there nipper
nothing doesn't cure that yeah how do I
sedate you there we'll come on you're
having a little too much fun no excuse
me sir I know hey what's up mark wants
to [ __ ] wait I think is what's going on
pretty much damn who's making nippers
hey guys I'm just kill myself real quick
where are you well Jamal you do that
just answer me this one question right
where you are
yeah where you are we're fine I did it
I'm join you soon Jamal just I don't I
don't understand where anyone is or
what's happening oh oh oh no oh no oh
[ __ ] where does that what do we need
were this I have a glove I just don't
know where he is
okay I'll look around oh god oh no no no
where where though just tell me where
you guys I can't find any of you guys
this game kill myself yeah I don't know
how you did anything I can't do [ __ ]
Hey what are you doing wait you missed
drop there [ __ ] he's trying to
burn himself down play this game we'll
play it our way Bob and I are gonna [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you yeah that's absolute Bob
this is absolutely necessary
okay I guess I want to be a horny boy
Jack sorry I'm sorry
no horny boy for you I'm going to hell
yep you sure it doesn't really say how
much time I have on my end decide 3/4 of
the type of gun by I'm gonna wake up how
much time do I have wait like five
seconds I'm sorry I'm sorry I just put
someone in there I didn't know that I
couldn't do that Bob I've [ __ ] you I'm
sorry that's fine it's fine
he's burning out there I'm going back to
get [ __ ] yeah yeah you just you just
stop complaining now we're gonna get
this nightmare over with that way we can
all go home I'm about to put one in mark
you're gonna have to find a new not so
fun easy now huh
not so fun I'm gonna get this but thing
and put it in weights but wait you want
a butt thing you wanna but I'm not kill
myself with a razor oh Jesus I'm
bleeding what the [ __ ] are the fire
extinguishers in this place there's not
a thing I could do about it
luring me I'm right in front of you
whatever wasted life I mean whatever
wait what do you think I mean wait am i
broken this is respawn in five not good
I'm trying I'm bleeding everywhere
I don't know yeah no you'll never stop
him damn it
I'm still just dead in here oh that's
right you guys still won yeah
I died in the J we won I would rather
play amazing frog oh I am totally down
for amazing frog amazing frog is awesome
thank you
[Music]